양자 정보와 계산 이해하기 강의에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Watrous이고 IBM Quantum 교육 기술 총괄이에요.
이번이 시리즈의 13번째 강의이고, 양자 오류에 관한 네 번째이자 마지막 단원의 첫 번째 강의예요.
정정이죠. Quantum Computing은 효율적인 고전 알고리즘이 알려지지 않은 계산 작업에 대해 효율적인 해결책을 가능하게 할 잠재력을 갖고 있어요.
그런데 아마 존재하지 않을 수도 있죠. 하지만 우리가 언젠가 가능하길 바라는 대규모 양자 계산을 구현하려면 극복해야 할 매우 중요한 과제들이 있어요.
그게 실현되려면 반드시 넘어야 할 벽들이 있는 거죠. 핵심 문제는 양자 정보가 엄청나게 취약하다는 거예요. 말 그대로 그냥 바라보기만 해도
망가질 수 있어요. 그래서 양자 컴퓨터가 제대로 작동하려면 자신이 저장하는 양자 정보를
주변 환경으로부터 극도로 차단해야 해요. 동시에 양자 컴퓨터 자체는 우리에게
이 양자 정보에 대한 매우 정밀한 제어를 제공해야 해요. 여기에는 올바른 초기화, 정확하고 신뢰할 수 있는
유니터리 연산, 그리고 당연히 측정을 수행할 수 있는 능력이 포함돼요. 그래야 실제로 계산 결과를 얻을 수 있죠.
계산 결과를 얻을 수 있어요. 이 요구 사항들 사이에는 분명히 긴장감이 있고, Quantum Computing 초창기에는 양자 정보의 취약성 때문에 어떤 사람들은
계산 결과를 얻을 수 있어요. 이 요구 사항들 사이에는 분명 긴장감이 있고, Quantum Computing 초창기에는 양자 정보의 취약성이
부정확성과 환경 노이즈 모두에 대한 취약성 때문에 결국 Quantum Computing을 불가능하게 만들 거라고 생각한 사람들도 있었어요. 오늘날에는 정확하고 신뢰할 수 있는
대규모 양자 컴퓨터를 만드는 것이 엄청난 도전이라는 데 거의 의심의 여지가 없어요. 하지만 우리에게는 이 노력에서 도움이 되는 핵심 도구가 있어요.
그 도구는 언젠가 대규모 Quantum Computing이 현실이 될 것이라고 이 분야에 정통한 대부분의 사람들을 낙관하게 만들어요. 그 도구는 바로 양자 오류
정정이에요. 다음 네 강의에서는 Quantum 오류 정정에 대해 기초에 초점을 맞춰 논의할 거예요.
이번 강의에서는 Quantum 오류 정정을 처음으로 살펴볼 건데, 최초로 발견된 양자 오류 정정 코드 중 하나인
9 qubit Shore 코드도 포함돼요. 또한 Quantum 오류 정정의 또 다른 기본 개념도 논의할 거예요.
바로 오류의 이산화라고 알려진 개념이에요. 단원의 이후 강의에서는 더 정교하고 궁극적으로 더 나은
Quantum 오류 정정 코드 구성을 살펴보고, 자체적으로 완벽하지 않고 오류가 발생하기 쉬운 계산 구성 요소를 사용하는 인코딩된 양자 정보에 대한 양자 계산 문제도 논의할 거예요.
계산 구성 요소를 사용하는 인코딩된 양자 정보에 대한 양자 계산 문제도 논의할 거예요. 강의의 간략한 개요를 알려드릴게요.
아마도 가장 단순하고 기본적인 유형의 고전 오류 정정 코드인 고전 반복 코드에 대한 논의로 시작할 거예요.
고전 오류 정정 코드에 대한 논의로 시작할 거예요. 고전 반복 코드는 고전적인
코딩 이론 기준으로는 특별히 좋은 코드가 아니에요. 적어도 단독으로는요. 하지만 괜찮아요. 여기서는 단순성을 추구하는 거니까요.
특히 우리는 상상할 수 있는 가장 단순한 고전 오류 정정 코드를 살펴볼 건데, 그걸 간단한 예시의 기초로 사용할 거예요.
그 예시는 바로 간단한 Quantum 오류 정정 코드예요. 자세히 논의할 그 예시는 9 qubit Shore 코드예요.
자세히 논의할 9 qubit Shore 코드가 그 예시예요. 코드 자체에 대한 설명과 함께
이 코드를 사용해 qubit를 인코딩하는 절차, 인코딩된 qubit의 오류 감지,
오류 정정도 포함돼요. 강의의 세 번째 부분에서는 오류의 이산화에 대해 논의할 건데, 이는 우리가
원칙적으로 연속적인 가능성을 형성하는 qubit의 임의적인 오류를 이산적인 용어로 생각할 수 있게 해줘요. 본질적으로 오류를
소위 비트 플립과 위상 플립으로 줄여주는 거죠. Quantum 오류 정정의 기술적인 세부 사항으로 들어가기 전에
잠깐 Quantum 오류 정정의 필요성과 함께 고전 오류 정정의 필요성도 생각해보는 게 좋을 것 같아요.
강의 시작에서 제가 말했듯이 양자 컴퓨터는 오류에 매우 취약한데, 이는
양자 정보의 취약성 때문이에요. 특히 환경, 즉
나머지 세계와의 원치 않는 상호작용이 양자 정보를 방해할 수 있어요. 이런 원치 않는 상호작용은 정보가
환경으로 새어 나가는 디코히어런스를 일으킬 수 있고, 양자 컴퓨터에 저장된 정보가 점점 더
고전적으로 행동하게 만들어요. 또한 양자 연산은 제한된
정확도로만 수행될 수 있다는 점을 인식하는 것도 매우 중요해요. 예를 들어 우리는 qubit에 특정 Quantum gate를 수행하고 싶을 수 있는데, 물리적 장치는
절대 완벽하지 않기 때문에 실제로 구현하는 건 그 gate의 근사치에 불과할 수 있어요. 단일 gate에서는 큰 문제가 아닐 수 있지만
우리의 의도가 수천 또는 수백만 개의 quantum gate를 수행하는 거라면, 이런 작은 부정확성들이
쌓이기 시작할 거예요. 계산이 끝나면 우리가
예상했던 것과 매우 다른 상태가 될 수 있어요. 이건 꽤 다른 오류 원인이지만 분명히 무시할 수 없는 것이에요.
사람들은 거의 한 세기 동안 고전 오류 정정 코드를 연구해 왔고, 이 코드들은 정보 전송 및 저장을 포함한 많은 응용 프로그램을 갖고 있어요.
하지만 고전 컴퓨팅 구성 요소가 매우 신뢰할 수 있기 때문에 우리는 실제로 고전 컴퓨터를 만드는 데 오류 정정이 필요하지 않아요.
신뢰할 수 있는 대규모 양자 컴퓨터를 만드는 데도 오류 정정이 실제로 필요하지 않을 수도 있어요. 예를 들어 위상 Quantum Computing의 핵심 아이디어는
노이즈에 대해 본질적으로 보호되는 강력한 Quantum 시스템을 구축할 수 있을 거라는 것인데,
시스템의 위상적 특성 때문에 그럴 수 있다는 거예요. 하지만 이게 가능할지 모르고, 대규모 Quantum Computing에는
오류 정정이 어떤 형태로든 아마 필수적일 거라고 꽤 널리 믿어지고 있어요. 이제 우리는 고전
반복 코드에 대해 논의할 건데, 이건 곧 보게 될 첫 번째 Quantum 오류 정정 코드인 9 qubit Shore 코드의 기초를 형성해요.
반복 코드는 오류 정정 코드의 극히 기본적인 예시예요.
반복 코드예요. 핵심 아이디어는 각 비트를 여러 번 반복함으로써 오류로부터 비트를 보호할 수 있다는 거예요. 특히
3비트 반복 코드를 살펴볼게요. 여기서 우리는 비트를 단순히 세 번 반복함으로써 하나의 비트를 세 개로 인코딩해요.
3비트 반복 코드를 살펴볼게요. 비트를 단순히 세 번 반복함으로써 하나의 비트를 세 개로 인코딩하는 거예요.
0은 000으로 인코딩되고 1은 111로 인코딩돼요. 물론 아무 문제가 없으면
두 가지 가능성을 쉽게 구별할 수 있어요. 하지만 오류가 있어서 비트 중 하나가 뒤집혔다면, 예를 들어
0이 1로 바뀌거나 1이 0으로 바뀐다면, 두 이진 값 중 어느 것이 두 번 나타나는지를 보면 원래 비트가 뭐였는지 알 수 있어요.
동등하게, 다수결 값을 계산해서 디코딩할 수 있어요.
즉 가장 자주 나타나는 이진 값을 찾는 거예요. 비트 플립 오류가 최대 하나라면
디코딩이 정확할 거라는 건 어렵지 않게 알 수 있어요. 물론 두 비트가 뒤집히거나
세 비트 모두 뒤집히면 작동하지 않고 디코딩할 때 잘못된 값을 얻게 돼요. 그건 일반적인 속성이에요.
모든 오류 정정 코드가 갖는 속성이죠. 일부 오류는 정정할 수 있지만 모든 오류를 정정할 수는 없어요. 결국 이건
정확성을 보장하는 것이 아니라 오류 가능성을 줄이는 것에 관한 거예요. 일반적으로 그건
가능한 거죠. 오류를 낼 가능성을 줄일 수 있는 상황의 예시로, 우리의
목표가 가상의 수신자에게 단일 비트를 전달하는 것이고, 이를 위해 비트를
소위 이진 대칭 채널을 통해 전송할 수 있다고 가정해 봐요. 이 채널은 전송되는 각 비트를 어떤 확률로 독립적으로 뒤집어요.
확률 P로요. 확률 1 빼기 P로 수신자는 우리가 보내려는 비트를 받겠지만, 확률 P로
비트가 뒤집혀서 수신자는 우리가 보낸 것과 반대 값을 받아요. 그래서 반복
코드를 사용하지 않고 그냥 생각하는 비트를 채널을 통해 보내면, 수신자는 잘못된 비트를 받을 거예요.
확률 P로요. 반면에 먼저 3비트 반복 코드를 사용해 보내려는 비트를 인코딩한 다음
인코딩의 세 비트 각각을 채널을 통해 보내면, 각각이 확률 P로 뒤집혀요.
이제 비트 플립 가능성은 더 높아지는데, 하나가 아닌 세 비트가 뒤집힐 수 있으니까요.
하지만 최대 하나의 비트만 뒤집힌다면 수신자는 올바르게 디코딩할 수 있어요. 그래서 오류는
전송 중에 두 개 이상의 비트가 뒤집힐 때만 디코딩 후 발생하는데, 이게 발생하는 확률을 계산하는 건 어렵지 않아요.
확률은 3 곱하기 P의 제곱 빼기 2 곱하기 P의 세제곱이에요. P가 1/2보다 작은 경우
수신자가 잘못된 비트를 얻을 확률이 줄어들어요. 이 경우에도 오류 가능성은 있지만
코드가 그 가능성을 줄여줘요. 가능성을 더 줄이고 싶다면 다른
코드를 사용해서 그렇게 할 수 있어요. 인코딩된 비트가 세 번 이상 반복되는 반복 코드를 사용하는 것도 포함해서요.
P가 1/2보다 큰 경우에는 그런데 이 코드가 실제로
수신자가 잘못된 비트를 얻을 가능성을 높인다는 의미에서 상황을 더 나쁘게 만들어요. 그래서 그런 상황에서는 당연히 이 코드를 사용하지 않겠죠.
3비트 반복 코드는 고전 오류 정정 코드지만, qubit에 대한 오류로부터 보호하는 데도 사용하려면 어떻게 되는지 생각해볼 수 있어요.
그렇게 좋은 Quantum 오류 정정 코드는 아니에요. 보게 되겠지만 일부 오류는 정정할 수 있지만 다른 오류는 더 발생하기 쉽게 만들어요.
하지만 Shore 코드를 향한 첫 번째 단계예요. 그러니 qubit에서 어떻게 작동하는지 봐요. 먼저 명확히 하자면, 3비트 반복 코드가 qubit에 사용된다고 할 때
우리가 생각하는 건 화면에 표시된 것처럼 qubit의 인코딩이에요. 여기서 알파 0 더하기 베타 1은
알파 000 더하기 베타 111로 인코딩돼요. 즉 표준 기저 상태가
세 번 반복되는 거예요. 특히 이건 양자 상태를 세 번 반복하는 것과는 다른 거예요. 주어진
양자 상태 s를 s 텐서 s 텐서 s로 인코딩하는 것과는 달리, 그건 우리가
미지의 양자 상태 s에 대해 구현할 수 없는 인코딩이에요. 복제 불가 정리 때문에요. 반면에 우리가 얘기하는
인코딩은 매우 쉽게 구현돼요. 여기 두 개의 초기화된 작업 qubit와 두 개의
제어 NOT gate를 사용하는 아주 간단한 Quantum circuit이 있어요. 자, 이제 인코딩이 수행된 후
오류가 발생한다고 가정해 봐요. 특히 Pauli X 연산, 즉 비트 플립이 qubit 중 하나에서 발생한다고
가정해 봐요. 이 그림에서는 중간 qubit이에요. 물론 이게 발생할 수 있는 유일한 오류는 아니고
오류가 이 완벽한 유니터리 연산의 형태를 취한다는 아이디어에 반대할 수도 있어요. 하지만 강의 후반부에 다시 이 부분으로 돌아올 거예요. 지금은 그냥
예시로 생각해요. 결과 상태는 이래요. 각 K 내의 중간 비트가 뒤집혔다는 점만 빼면
원래 인코딩과 동일해요. 물론 우리는 상태의 수학적 표현을 통해 이걸 볼 수 있어요.
하지만 세 qubit만 있고 비트 플립이 발생했을 수 있다고 의심하지만 어떤 qubit에 영향을 미쳤는지 모른다고 가정해 봐요.
비트 플립이 발생했는지 알아내는 한 가지 방법은 표준 기저 측정을 수행하고 결과를 검사하는 거예요. 이 경우 우리는
알파와 베타에 따른 확률로 010 또는 101을 보게 될 거예요. 두 경우 모두 결론은
중간 비트가 뒤집혔다는 거예요. 하지만 불행히도 그것은 원래 양자 상태를 망가뜨려요. 그리고 이 상태는
우리에게 소중할 수 있어요. 결국 전체 목적이 이 양자 상태를 보호하는 거잖아요. 그래서 이건 좋은
선택지가 아니에요. 대신 우리가 할 수 있는 건 화면에 표시된 quantum circuit를 사용하는 거예요. 인코딩된 상태를
상위 세 qubit에 입력하는 거예요. 기본적으로 이 circuit가 하는 건 표준의 패리티를 계산하는 거예요.
상위 두 qubit에 대한 기저 상태뿐만 아니라 인코딩의 하위 두 qubit에 대해서도요. 이렇게 하면
비트 플립의 위치가 드러나요. 특히 이 경우 두 패리티 검사 모두에서 결과 1을 얻을 거예요.
그 정보로부터 중간 비트가 다른 두 비트와 다르다는 결론을 내릴 수 있어요. 그래서 그게 분명히
뒤집힌 거예요. 그리고 중요한 건 이게 상태 붕괴를 일으키지 않는다는 거예요. 이제 이 비트를 정정하려는 시도를 해볼 수 있어요.
그래서 결국 원래 상태를 디코딩하고 되찾을 수 있을 거예요. 정정 부분으로는
잠시 후에 돌아올 거예요. 하지만 먼저 비트 플립 오류의 다른 가능성들을 간단히 살펴봐요. 대신 비트 플립 오류가
하단 또는 왼쪽 qubit에서 발생했다면 아래에서 위로 읽어서 결과 10을 얻을 거예요.
그리고 다시 상태는 변하지 않아요. 만약 비트 플립이 상단 qubit에서 발생했다면 결과는
01이 될 거예요. 그리고 다시 상태는 변하지 않아요. 그리고 만약
비트 플립 오류가 전혀 없었다면 측정 결과는 00이고 다시 상태는 변하지 않아요.
이걸 표 형태로 요약해 볼게요. 최대 하나의 비트 플립으로 얻을 수 있는 각 가능한 상태를 나열하고, 측정
결과인 오류 정정 맥락에서 신드롬이라고 부르는 것과, 원래
인코딩을 되찾기 위해 해야 할 정정을 나열해요. 오류가 없었다면 신드롬은 00이고 상태를 고치기 위해 아무것도 할 필요가 없어요.
하단 또는 왼쪽 qubit에서 비트 플립이 발생했다면 신드롬은 10이고 적절한 정정은
하단 또는 왼쪽 qubit에 X gate를 적용하는 거예요. 다른 두 경우도
비슷해요. 그래서 신드롬을 기반으로 적절한 정정을 적용하면 네 가지 경우 모두에서 원래
인코딩을 확실히 복구할 수 있어요. 다시 한번, 최대 하나의 비트
플립 오류만 발생했을 가능성만 고려하고 있어요. 두 개나 세 개의 비트가 뒤집히면 제대로 작동하지 않고, 다른 오류의
가능성도 아직 고려하지 않았어요. 이제 양자 환경에서 다른 유형의 오류를 고려해 봐요. 비트
플립 오류는 우리가 걱정해야 할 유일한 오류가 아니에요. 예를 들어 위상 플립
오류, 줄여서 위상 플립도 걱정해야 해요. 이는 Z gate, 즉 Pauli Z로 표현돼요.
연산이에요. 안타깝게도 3비트 반복 코드는 위상 플립을 감지하는 데 완전히 실패해요. 예를 들어, 우리가
이전처럼 3비트 반복 코드로 qubit를 인코딩하고 중간 qubit에 위상 플립 오류가 발생한다고 가정하면
화면에 표시된 상태를 얻게 돼요. 이건 인코딩하기 전에 원래 qubit에 위상 플립이 발생했을 때 얻었을 인코딩과 정확히 같아요.
그래서 같은 방식으로
이전과 같은 circuit를 수행해서 오류를 감지하려 하면 신드롬 00을 얻게 돼요. 이는 오류가 없었다고 잘못 제안하는 거예요.
그래서 3비트 반복 코드는 최대 하나의 비트 플립 오류에는 작동하지만 위상 플립 오류를 감지하는 데는 실패해요.
사실 어떤 의미에서는 상황을 더 나쁘게 만드는데, 위상 플립을 경험할 수 있는 qubit이 세 배나 더 많아지니까요.
3비트 반복 코드가 위상 플립 오류를 완전히 무시한다는 걸 알았어요. 그러니 이런 종류의 오류를 다루는 데는 별로 도움이 안 되는 것 같아요.
하지만 사실 3비트 반복 코드를 수정해서 위상 플립 오류도 감지하도록 만들 수 있어요. 이게 어떻게 되는지 지금 설명할게요.
3비트 반복 코드를 사용해 qubit를 인코딩하는 원래 circuit가 있고, 우리가 수정하는 방법은 매우 간단해요. 그냥
인코딩의 각 qubit에 Hadamard gate를 적용하면 돼요. Hadamard gate는 0 상태를 플러스 상태로 변환하고 1
상태를 마이너스 상태로 변환해요. 그래서 순 효과는 화면에 표시된 상태를 얻는 거예요. 여기서
플러스 플러스 플러스와 마이너스 마이너스 마이너스는 세 플러스 상태 또는 세 마이너스의 텐서에 대한 약식 표기예요.
상태죠. 위상 플립 오류, 즉 Z gate는 플러스 상태를 마이너스 상태로, 마이너스 상태를
플러스 상태로 변환해요. 그래서 이 인코딩은 위상 플립 오류를 감지하고 정정하는 데 유용할 거예요. 그러기 위해 이전의
오류 감지 circuit를 다음과 같이 수정할 수 있어요.
이전 circuit에서 화면에 표시된 것처럼 시작과 끝에 Hadamard gate를 추가할 거예요.
아이디어는 매우 간단해요. 처음 세 Hadamard gate가 플러스와 마이너스 상태를 다시 0과 1 상태로 변환해요.
같은 패리티 검사가 이전처럼 수행되고, 두 번째 Hadamard gate 레이어가 우리를
인코딩으로 되돌려요. 이를 생각하는 다른 방법은 기본적으로 Hadamard 연산으로 켤레를 취함으로써 위상 플립 오류를 비트 플립 오류로 변환하는 거예요.
그런데 circuit를 조금 단순화할 수 있어요. 이 circuit는 완전히 동일해요.
원하신다면 직접 확인해 보세요. 인코딩된 qubit를 이 circuit에 넣으면
위상 플립 오류가 발생하지 않았다고 가정하면 신드롬 00을 얻어요. 위상 플립이 없었음을 나타내는 거죠.
오류가 없다는 걸 나타내요. 상단 qubit에 위상 플립 오류가 있다면, 가장 오른쪽 플러스와 마이너스가 뒤집혀요.
그러면 다른 오류 신드롬 01이 나와요. 이 경우 비트 플립에서 했던 것처럼 위상 플립의 위치를 식별해요.
그러면 상단 qubit에 Z gate를 적용해서 정정할 수 있어요. 상황은
다른 두 qubit 중 하나에서 위상 플립 오류가 발생한 경우에도 비슷해요. 사실 이 코드를 사용해서 최대 하나의 위상 플립 오류를 감지하고
정정할 수 있어요. 하지만 안타깝게도 이미 짐작하셨을 수 있지만, 이제 더 이상
비트 플립 오류를 정정할 수 없어요. 하지만 아직 희망은 있어요. 사실 이 두 코드를
결합해서 비트 플립과 위상 플립 오류 모두 정정할 수 있는 코드를 얻을 수 있거든요. 실제로
단일 qubit의 임의적인 오류를 정정할 수 있게 될 거예요. 이제 9 qubit Shore 코드에 대해 논의할 시간이에요. 이건 Quantum
오류 정정 코드로, 우리가 방금 본 두 코드, 즉 3비트를 결합해서 얻을 수 있어요.
단일 비트 플립 오류를 정정할 수 있는 반복 코드와 단일 위상 플립을 정정할 수 있는 수정된 버전을 결합하는 거예요.
오류를 결합하는 거예요. 더 정확하게 말하면, 9 qubit Shore 코드는 두 코드를 연결해서 얻는 코드예요. 이는
먼저 하나의 qubit를 세 개로 인코딩하는 하나의 인코딩을 적용하고, 그다음 각
세 qubit에 개별적으로 다른 인코딩을 적용하는 걸 의미해요. 그래서 총 9개의 qubit를 얻게 돼요. 이를
circuit 다이어그램 형태로 다음과 같이 표현할 수 있어요. 먼저 위상 플립 오류를 감지하는 3비트 반복 코드의 수정된 버전을 적용하고
오류를 감지할 거예요. 그런 다음 원래의
3비트 반복 코드를 사용해 결과 qubit를 독립적으로 각각 인코딩해요. circuit를 조금 줄이면
좀 더 공간을 만들 수 있는데, 원래 qubit에 대한 두 표준 기저 상태가 어떻게
인코딩되는지를 설명함으로써 코드를 약간 다른 방식으로 지정할 수 있어요.
이걸 알면 선형성에 의해 임의적인 qubit 상태 벡터가 어떻게
인코딩되는지 결정할 수 있어요. 그게 바로 9 qubit Shore 코드예요. 한 코드가 위상 플립을 정정하고
다른 코드가 비트 플립 오류를 정정해요. 앞으로 보게 되겠지만 이는 실제로 단일 qubit의 임의적인 오류를 정정할 수 있음을 의미해요.
이제 9 qubit Shore 코드를 사용해서 오류를 감지하고 정정하는 방법을 알아봐요. 비트 플립 오류, X 오류라고도 하는 것부터 시작할게요.
인코딩을 수행하는 circuit가 있고, 얘기하기 쉽게 이 코드에서 얻는 9개의 qubit를
세 개의 qubit로 이루어진 세 블록으로 그룹화해서 생각할 거예요. 각 블록은
두 번째 인코딩 단계를 적용해서 얻는 인코딩을 나타내요.
두 번째 인코딩 단계는 이 맥락에서 내부 코드라고 불리는 일반 3비트 반복 코드예요.
반면 외부 코드는 첫 번째 인코딩 단계에 사용되는 코드로, 이 경우 위상 플립 오류에 작동하는
3비트 반복 코드의 수정된 버전이에요. 비트 플립 오류를 정정하려면 각 블록을
개별적으로 처리하면 돼요. 각 블록은 3비트 반복 코드를 사용한 qubit의 인코딩이고
그 코드는 비트 플립 오류로부터 보호해요. 먼저 qubit 중 하나에 X 오류가 발생한다고 가정해 봐요.
예를 들어 중간 블록의 중간 qubit처럼요. 각 블록을 독립적으로 비트 플립 오류가 있는지 검사하고
발견된 오류를 정정하면, 이 오류는 정정되고 원래 인코딩이
복구될 거예요. 사실 여러 X 오류가 있어도 오류가
별도의 블록에 있는 한 이런 방식으로 정정할 수 있어요. 단일 블록에 두 개 또는 세 개의 X 오류가 있으면 문제가 되지만
블록당 최대 하나의 X 오류만 있다면 내부 코드가 이를 잡아내고 원래 인코딩된 상태를 복구할 수 있어요.
그래서 이 코드에서 비트 플립 오류를 정정하는 건 꽤 간단한 문제예요. 위상 플립 오류도 고려해야 해요.
즉 Z 오류예요. 이번에는 무엇을 해야 할지가 그렇게 명확하지 않아요. 외부 코드가 위상 플립 오류를 정정하는 것이지만
내부 코드가 어떻게든 방해하기 때문에 직접적으로 감지하고 정정할 수 없어요.
하지만 곧 어떻게 하는지 알게 될 거예요. X와 Z
오류가 어떻게 작동하고 Quantum circuit 내에서 어떤 효과를 갖는지 더 잘 이해하려면, 이 오류들과 CNOT
gate 사이의 몇 가지 간단한 관계를 살펴보는 게 도움이 돼요. 이건 나중 강의에서도 유용할 거예요. 먼저 X 오류부터 시작해요.
X gate와 CNOT gate의 관계예요. 만약 CNOT의
타겟 qubit에 X gate를 적용한 다음 CNOT을 적용하면, 이는 순서를 바꿔서 CNOT을 먼저 하는 것과 동일해요.
반면에 CNOT의 제어 qubit에 X gate를 적용한 다음 CNOT을 적용하면, 단순히
순서를 바꿀 수는 없고 대신 두 qubit 모두에 X gate를 적용해야 해요. 원하신다면 이 모든 관계를
직접 확인해볼 수 있어요. 예를 들어 표준 기저 상태에 무슨 일이 일어나는지 생각해보면 돼요. Z
오류의 경우도 비슷한데, 제어와 타겟 qubit의 역할이 바뀌어요. 특히
CNOT의 제어 qubit에 Z gate를 수행하고 CNOT을 수행하면, 이는
CNOT 후에 Z gate를 수행하는 것과 같은 효과예요. 하지만 대신 타겟 qubit에 Z gate를 수행하면
이는 먼저 CNOT을 수행하고 두 qubit 모두에 Z gate를 적용하는 것과 동일해요. 마지막으로 이 모든
관계들은 각 방정식 양쪽의 gate 순서를 항상 바꿀 수 있다는 의미에서 대칭이에요.
이는 양쪽의 역행렬 또는 켤레 전치를 취하는 것과 동일한데, X, Z 및 CNOT
gate는 모두 자기 자신의 역행렬이기 때문이에요. 이제 위상 플립 오류와 이를 9 qubit Shore 코드로 감지하고 정정하는 방법을 살펴봐요.
인코딩 circuit가 있고, 9개의 qubit를 계속해서
세 qubit로 이루어진 세 블록으로 그룹화해서 생각할 거예요. 한 qubit에 Z 오류가 발생한다고 가정해요.
여기 표시된 것처럼요. Z gate와 CNOT gate에 대해 방금 관찰한 것을 사용하면,
이는 CNOT 이전에 두 개의 Z 오류, 하나는 제어 qubit에, 하나는 타겟 qubit에 발생하는 것과 동일해요.
이 오류들은 블록의 다른 CNOT과 교환 가능해요. 그래서 우리는
순서를 바꿀 수 있고 다음 결과를 얻어요. 하위 Z 오류는 0 상태에서 작동하기 때문에 아무것도 하지 않아요.
나머지를 밀어서 이 다이어그램을 얻어요. 우리가 발견한 건 중간 블록 어딘가의 Z 오류는
두 번째 인코딩 단계 이전에 중간 qubit에서 Z 오류가 발생하는 것과 동일하다는 거예요.
블록의 어느 qubit에 Z 오류가 발생해도 정확히 같은 방식으로 추론할 수 있어요. 블록 내 어느 qubit의 위상 플립도
내부 인코딩 이전의 해당 qubit의 위상 플립과 동일해요. Z 오류가 3비트 반복 코드에 어떻게 영향을 미치는지 생각해보면 실제로 꽤 직관적이에요.
그래서 Z 오류를 처리하는 한 가지 방법은 내부 코드를 디코딩한 다음 외부 코드를 사용해 Z 오류를 감지하고 정정하는 거예요. 외부 코드는
Z 오류를 정정할 수 있는 3비트 반복 코드의 수정된 버전이에요. 그래서 Z 오류가 정정되고
원하면 내부 코드로 재인코딩할 수 있어요. 또한 Z 오류를 제자리에서 정정할 수도 있어요.
디코딩하고 재인코딩하지 않고 그렇게 하는 거예요. 꽤 직관적이지만 어떻게 할 수 있는지 설명하려면
좀 더 공간이 필요해요. 내부 코드를 디코딩한다고 가정해 봐요.
그런 다음 외부 코드만의 세 qubit만 포함해서 이전과 같은 방법으로 외부 코드의 신드롬을 계산해요.
그런 다음 재인코딩해요. CNOT을 조금 단순화할 수 있고
방금 전에 관찰한 NOT gate와 CNOT gate 사이의 관계를 사용해서 그 작업을 도울 수 있어요.
이렇게 하면 CNOT 네 개를 절약할 수 있고 이게 우리가 얻는 circuit예요. 한 qubit에 Z 오류가 발생했다면
신드롬이 알려주는 건 이제 어떤 qubit에 Z 오류가 발생했는지가 아니라 어느 블록에 Z 오류가
발생했는지예요. 하지만 괜찮아요. 블록 내 어느 qubit에 Z 오류가 발생하든 상관없다는 걸 알고 있으니까요.
효과는 그 블록 내 세 qubit 모두에서 동일해요. 그래서 사실 그 블록의 어느 qubit에든 Z gate를 적용해서 Z 오류를 정정할 수 있어요.
어느 qubit에든 적용해도 돼요. 그런데 이건 오류 정정 코드에서 축퇴성이라고 불리는 것의 예시예요.
주어진 오류를 고유하게 식별하지 않고도 정정할 수 있는 거죠. 마지막으로 비트 플립과 위상 플립 오류가 모두 발생한다고 가정해 봐요.
같은 qubit에서 발생할 수도 있어요. 예를 들어
이 qubit에서 비트 플립과 위상 플립 오류가 발생한다고 가정해 봐요.
여기 있는 qubit에서요. 이 오류들은 완전히 독립적으로 감지하고 정정할 수 있어요.
사실 각 블록에서 비트 플립을 먼저 정정한 다음 위상 플립을 정정하든, 반대 순서로 하든 상관없어요.
이를 이해하기 위해 먼저 이 오류들의 순서는 상관없다는 걸 관찰해요. 원하면 뒤집을 수 있어요. 그 이유는
X와 Z가 교환 가능하기 때문이 아니에요. 교환 가능하지 않으니까요. X 곱하기 Z는 음의 Z 곱하기 X와 같아요.
하지만 이 경우 -1 인수는 전역 위상이기 때문에 효과가 없어요. 이제 전과 같이 Z 오류를 이동할 수 있고
이 시점에서, 먼저 각 블록에서 X 오류를 정정한 다음 Z 오류를 정정하면
두 오류 모두 정정될 거라는 게 명백해요. 반대로 어떤 이유로
Z 오류를 먼저 정정하기로 했다면, X 오류는 그 과정에서 아무런 영향을 미치지 않아요.
그건 사실이어야 해요. 첫 번째로 X 오류가 외부 코드의 신드롬을 계산하는 circuit의 모든 gate와 교환 가능하기 때문이에요.
두 번째로 정정을 위해 적용하는 Z gate와 X 오류 사이의 순서는
Z gate가 오류였을 때 주장했던 것처럼 상관없어요. 그래서 Z
오류를 정정할 수 있고, 그런 다음 X 오류를 제거하기 위해 각 블록을 정정할 수 있어요. 우리가 주장한 건 이 코드를 사용해서 qubit 중 어느 하나에서
X 오류, Z 오류 또는 둘 다를 정정할 수 있다는 거예요.
사실 그 이상의 오류도 정정할 수 있어요. 예를 들어 다른 블록에 있는 한 여러 X 오류나
최대 하나의 블록만 홀수 개를 받는 한 여러 Z 오류도 정정할 수 있어요. 하지만 앞으로 가장 관련성이 높은 건
어느 하나의 qubit에서 X 오류, Z 오류 또는 둘 다를 정정할 수 있다는 거예요. 강의의 마지막 부분에서
이것이 이 코드가 어느 하나의 qubit에서 임의적인 오류를 정정할 수 있다는 결론을 내리기에 충분한 이유를 알 수 있을 거예요.
임의적인 Quantum 오류를 고려할 강의의 마지막 부분으로 넘어가기 전에, Pauli 행렬로 표현된 오류가 무작위로 발생하는 경우
N qubit Shore 코드의 성능을 간단히
살펴볼 거예요.
qubit에 대해 더 구체적으로, 오류가 qubit에 독립적으로 발생하는 간단한 노이즈 모델을 생각해 봐요.
각 qubit는 확률 p로 오류를 경험하고 다른 qubit의 오류 사이에는 상관관계가 없어요.
9 qubit Shore 코드의 최악의 시나리오는 Y 오류, 즉 X 오류와 Z
오류 모두가 영향받은 각 qubit에서 발생하는 거예요. 우리는 코드 성능의 한계를 구하기 위해 이 최악의 시나리오를 가정할 거예요.
하지만 세 Pauli 오류가 동일하게 발생할 가능성이 있다고 고려할 수도 있어요. 이제 Q가 오류로부터 보호하고 싶은 특정 상태의 qubit라고 가정하고
9 qubit Shore 코드를 사용할 옵션이 있다고 상상해 봐요. 사용해야 할까요? 답은 반드시 그렇지는 않아요.
왜냐하면 노이즈가 너무 많거나 즉 p가 너무 크면 Shore 코드를 사용하는 게 실제로 상황을
더 나쁘게 만들 수 있기 때문이에요. p가 1/2보다 큰 경우 반복 코드에서 그랬던 것처럼요. 하지만 p가 충분히 작으면
코드를 사용해야 해요. 그러니 왜 그런지, 그리고 p가 이 코드에 비해 너무 크거나 충분히 작다는 게 무슨 의미인지 알아봐요.
Shore 코드는 단일 qubit의 임의적인 Pauli 오류를 정정할 수 있고, 최악의 경우
Pauli 오류가 Y 오류인 경우 이는 코드가 화면에 표시된 식으로 주어진 확률로 Q를 성공적으로 보호한다는 걸 의미해요.
구체적으로 코드는 오류가 없을 때 작동하는데, 이는
아홉 qubit가 각각 영향을 받지 않아야 하기 때문에 확률 (1-p)의 9승으로 발생해요. 그리고 정확히 하나의 오류가 있을 때 작동하는데
영향을 받을 수 있는 anh 개의 다른 qubit가 있다는 걸 고려하면 이는 확률 9 곱하기 p 곱하기 (1-p)의 8승으로 발생해요.
반면에 코드를 사용하지 않으면 하나뿐인 qubit가 확률 1 빼기 p로
오류에 영향을 받지 않아요. 그래서 코드는 첫 번째 확률이 두 번째보다 클 때만 도움이 돼요.
이 식들이 두 경우, 즉 코드를 사용하는 경우와 사용하지 않는 경우의 성공 확률을 나타내기 때문이에요.
여기에 p의 작은 값에 대한 이 두 함수의 그래프가 있어요. 손익분기점은
약 3과 3/4 퍼센트에서 발생해요. 그래서 p가 이 값보다 작으면 코드가
도움이 돼요. 손익분기점에서 확률은 같아서, 코드를 사용하면 8개의 qubit와 함께 그냥 시간을 낭비하는 거예요.
하지만 그 외에는 해롭지 않아요. 그 이상에서는 이 코드를 절대 사용하면 안 돼요.
왜냐하면 실제로 인코딩된 qubit에서 오류 가능성을 높이고 있기 때문인데, 이 맥락에서 우리는 그걸 일반적으로
논리적 qubit이라고 불러요. 이는 단순히 9개의 qubit에서 두 개 이상의 오류 가능성이
이 범위의 p 값에서 단일 qubit에서 하나의 오류 가능성보다 크기 때문이에요. 3과 3/4 퍼센트는 별로 좋지 않아 보일 수 있어요.
특히 고전 정보의 3비트 반복 코드의 유사한 손익분기점인 50%와 비교하면요.
하지만 양자 정보를 보호하는 건 더 어려워요. 게다가 이 코드는
최초의 Quantum 오류 정정 코드로서 훌륭한 발견이고 교육 목적으로는 훌륭하지만, 실제로는
그렇게 좋은 코드가 아니에요. 지금까지 9 qubit Shore 코드의 맥락에서 X 오류와
Z 오류를 고려했어요. 이제 임의적인 오류를 고려해 봐요.
먼저 유니터리 오류부터 시작해요. 예를 들어 그런 오류는 블로흐 구의 매우 작은
회전에 해당할 수 있어요. 완벽하지 않은 gate로 인한 오류를 나타낼 수 있어요.
또는 qubit에 대한 다른 유니터리 연산일 수도 있고 반드시 항등 연산에 가까운 건 아니에요.
그런 오류를 정정하는 게 어려울 것 같아요. 이런 오류는 무한히 많이 가능해서
정확히 어떤 오류인지 식별하고 되돌리는 건 상상할 수 없어요. 하지만 우리는
이미 논의한 것과 다른 뭔가를 할 필요는 없어요. 비트 플립이나 위상 플립 또는 둘 다 정정할 수 있는 한
실제로 임의적인 단일 qubit 유니터리 오류를 정정하는 데 성공할 거예요. 왜 그런지 지금 설명할게요.
모든 2x2 행렬처럼 단일 qubit의 오류를 나타내는 임의적인 유니터리 행렬을
먼저 항등 행렬을 포함한 네 Pauli 행렬의 선형 결합으로 표현할 수 있어요.
그런데 눈치채셨겠지만 비항등 Pauli 행렬을 나타내기 위해 대문자 X, Y, Z를 사용하고 있어요.
이 시리즈의 나머지 부분에서도 계속 그렇게 할 거예요. Quantum 오류 정정에서는 관례적이고
이 맥락에서 읽기도 조금 더 쉬워요. 또한 주어진 qubit 유니터리 연산이 어떤 qubit에 작용하는지 나타내기 위해 아래 첨자를 사용하는 게 편리할 거예요.
주어진 qubit에 작용하는지 나타내기 위해서요. 예를 들어 Qiskit의
qubit 번호 매기기 관례를 사용해 오른쪽 qubit 0부터 시작하면, 화면에 표시된 식을 얻어요.
단일 qubit에 대한 다양한 유니터리 연산에 대해, 각 경우에 유니터리 행렬을 모든 다른 qubit에 대한 항등 행렬과 텐서 곱해요.
그래서 특히 qubit K에 적용된 U를 의미하는 UK를 이전과 같은
선형 결합으로 표현할 수 있는데, 각 Pauli 행렬이 qubit K에 적용된다는 점만 달라요. 항등에 대한 아래 첨자는 신경 쓰지 않아도 돼요.
여기서 이해해야 할 건 이게 모든 qubit에 대한 항등이라는 거예요.
이제 사이가 qubit 상태의 9 qubit 인코딩이라고 가정해 봐요. 오류 U가 qubit k에 발생하면
UK 곱하기 사이를 얻는데, 이를 사이에 작용하는 Pauli 연산의 선형 결합으로 표현할 수 있어요.
물론 항등의 경우 이건 그냥 사이예요. 이 시점에서 Pauli Y 행렬이
i 곱하기 X 곱하기 Z와 같다는 걸 관찰하면 도움이 돼요. 그래서 식에서 그 대체를 할 수 있어요.
이 대체를 할 수 있어요. 그래서 이 오류가 발생했고 이제 이전과 같은 절차를 사용해서 정정을 시도한다고 가정해 봐요.
첫 번째 단계는 신드롬을 계산하는 건데, Shore 코드의 경우 8비트 길이예요. 내부 코드를 사용하는 세 번 각각에 두 비트씩과
외부 코드에 추가 두 비트예요. 하지만 실제로는 중요하지 않고 그냥 고정 길이 문자열로 생각할 수 있어요.
신드롬 측정 직전에 얻는 상태에 대한 설명이에요. 각 신드롬은 해당 Pauli 오류에서 얻는 8비트예요.
이 시점에서 두 시스템은 일반적으로 얽혀 있다는 걸 주목해요. 이게 모든 걸 작동하게 만드는 핵심이에요. 신드롬을 측정하면
효과적으로 상태를 붕괴시켜서 네 Pauli 연산 중 하나가 사이의 K번째 qubit에 적용된 상태가 돼요.
사이의 K번째 qubit에 적용된 상태가 되고, 신드롬을 통해 어떤 Pauli 연산인지 알 수 있어요. 그래서 필요하면 정정할 수 있어요.
특히 신드롬을 측정하고 적절한 정정을 하면
K번째 qubit가 사이의 상태를 얻어요. 그리고 신드롬을 통해 어떤 Pauli 연산인지 알 수 있어요.
필요하면 정정할 수 있어요. 특히 신드롬을 측정하고 적절한 정정을 하면
화면에 표시된 형태의 상태를 얻는데, 중요하게도 이건 곱 상태예요. 오른쪽 텐서 인수로 원래 손상되지 않은 인코딩이 있는데
이게 여기서 가장 중요한 거예요. 왼쪽에는 무작위 오류 신드롬을 설명하는 밀도 행렬 s가 있어요.
하지만 우리가 신경 쓰는 시스템과 더 이상 어떤 상관관계도 없어요.
오른쪽에 있는 거요. 오류가 이 시점에서 정정되었기 때문이에요. 신드롬 qubit를 버리거나 다시 사용하고 싶다면 리셋할 수 있어요.
그리고 그게 실제로 꽤 중요해요. 왜냐하면 이게 오류에 의해 생성된 무작위성이나 엔트로피가
시스템에서 제거되는 방식이기 때문이에요. 그리고 그게 적어도 유니터리
오류에 대해 오류의 이산화가 작동하는 방식이에요. 본질적으로 신드롬을 측정함으로써 효과적으로 오류를
Pauli 행렬로 설명되는 오류로 투영해요. 언뜻 보기에 임의적인 유니터리 오류를
정정할 수 있다는 게 너무 좋아서 사실이 아닌 것 같을 수 있어요. 그 자체로는 작고 거의 눈에 띄지 않는 오류도요. 하지만 여기서 중요하게 깨달아야 할 건
이게 단일 qubit에 대한 유니터리 오류라는 거예요. 코드의 설계상 단일 qubit 연산은 인코딩되는 논리적 qubit의 상태를 바꿀 수 없어요.
모든 게 할 수 있는 건 유효한 인코딩 공간 밖으로 상태를 이동시키는 것뿐이에요.
하지만 정정이 원래 있던 곳으로 다시 가져와요. 마지막으로 임의적이고 반드시 유니터리가 아닌 오류가 발생하면 어떻게 되는지 살펴봐요.
설정은 이전과 같아요.
Shore 코드를 사용해 하나의 qubit를 9개로 인코딩했고, qubit 채널로 표현되는 임의적인 오류가
qubit 중 하나에서 발생해요. 보게 되겠지만 모든 게 유니터리 오류에서와 거의 같은 방식으로 작동할 거예요.
이를 검증하는 첫 번째 단계는 오류의 Kraus 표현을 고려하는 거예요.
이제 유니터리 오류와 정확히 같은 추론을 따를 수 있는데, 오류를 나타내는 단일 유니터리 행렬 대신 Kraus 행렬에 그 추론을 적용하는 거예요.
오류를 나타내는 단일 유니터리 행렬 대신에요.
특히 각 Kraus 행렬은 Pauli 행렬의 선형 결합으로 표현될 수 있고, 이를 통해
이 오류 fi가 발생하는 qubit K에 대한 작용을 화면에 표시된 형태로 표현할 수 있어요.
여기서 우리가 실제로 하는 건 Kraus 행렬을 Pauli
행렬의 선형 결합으로 펼치는 거예요. 그런 다음 오류 신드롬을 계산하고 측정해서 드러난 오류를 정정하면
유니터리 오류의 경우와 비슷한 상태를 얻을 거예요. 세부 사항은 다루지 않을게요. 모두 유니터리
경우와 꽤 비슷하고 표현하기가 조금 더 복잡하지만 개념적으로는 꽤
직관적이에요. 이 모든 게 여러 qubit에서 오류를 정정할 수 있는 코드를 포함한 다른 Quantum 오류 정정 코드로 일반화된다는 걸 언급해야 해요.
그런 경우 여러 qubit의 오류는 Pauli
행렬의 텐서 곱의 선형 결합으로 표현될 수 있고, 이에 따라 다른 가능한 신드롬들이 하나가 아닌 여러 qubit에 수행되는 정정을 설명해요.
qubit에 수행되는 정정을요. 하지만 기본 아이디어는 다시 정확히 같아요. 신드롬을 측정함으로써
효과적으로 오류를 Pauli 행렬의 텐서 곱으로 표현되는 이산적인 가능성 집합으로 투영하거나 붕괴시켜요.
Pauli 행렬의 텐서 곱으로요. 그리고 그 오류들, 즉 Pauli 오류를 정정함으로써 원래
인코딩된 상태를 복구할 수 있어요. 한편 이 과정에서 생성된 무작위성은 신드롬 qubit로 이동되는데, 그걸 버리거나
리셋할 수 있어요. 이게 중요한데, 오류와 신드롬 측정에 의해 생성된 엔트로피가 시스템에서 제거되는 방식이기 때문이에요.
시스템에서 제거돼요. 이것으로 강의를 마쳐요. 이번 강의에서는 9 qubit Shore 코드와 오류의 이산화를 포함한
Quantum 오류 정정을 처음으로 살펴봤어요. 다음 강의에도 함께하시길 바라요.
다음 강의에서는 안정자 형식주의에 대해 논의할 건데, 이는 대규모의 흥미로운 클래스의 양자 오류 정정 코드를 설명하고
분석하기 위한 강력한 도구를 제공해요. 실제 양자 컴퓨터의 유망한 후보들도 포함해서요.
그때까지 안녕히 계세요.